– Das System wurde
sehr genau durchgeplant.
Die Bestellungen müssen schnell
und effizient laufen.
Dafür brauchen wir eine stabile App
und zusätzliche Arbeitskräfte.
– Eventuell müssen wir
die Küche auch vergrößern.
– Richtig. Der Lieferservice muss
von Anfang an perfekt funktionieren.
Sonst bestellt niemand zweimal.
– Ich stimme zu.
– Das … ist gut.
Haben Sie sonst noch Fragen?
– Erst einmal nicht.
– Und was sagen Sie?
– Ich denke darüber nach.
Ich melde mich in den nächsten
Tagen wieder bei Ihnen.
– Was? Das war’s?
– Ja. Jetzt müssen wir warten.
– Ich trau dem Ganzen nicht.
– Tarek …
– Ja, ja, wir warten.
Wer möchte etwas trinken?
– Ja.
– Selma! Entschuldigung, ich …
– Nico … Nico …
– Was machst du hier?
Wissen deine Eltern,
dass du hier bist? Selma …
– Ich muss es dir persönlich sagen.
– Was …
was musst du mir persönlich sagen?
– Wir können uns nicht mehr sehen, Nico.
Es tut mir leid, ich ... mag dich.
– Selma!